but like the whole point is you don't  have to go to court over it now I would  like to settle it outside but that that  it I you can't if I can't let me finish  that go ahead  I have tried to settle this outside and  there's still a chance that we could  right  I have given my financial affidavit  they've subpoenaed my stuff they know  what's going all in my business they  know what's going on  it is I do not have the final say okay  so if he doesn't want to settle he does  not have to we can have a judge tell us  who should be awarded what and leave it  up to chance like I said I wanted to  settle from the very beginning it  doesn't matter what I want because I'm  asking him this is what our bills are  this is how much it would be very  reasonable number based on again you  can't lie in the financial affidavit is  it like they subpoena everything so  that's where there's full transparency  it's